and then also uh Daniel Kelly who's one
of my favorites the little Phenom Jiu
Jitsu is fighting Jessica Khan that is
the first ever female Adam weight
submission grappling World title on one
Championship you know I'm sorry with my
girl Daniel Kelly Philly's Finest born
and raised in Philadelphia they flew her
out from New York to sit down and she
will be on one-on-one with me this week
to preview her fight just her life
struggles everything she's gone through
to get to this point in her life and
she's one of the baddest women on the
freaking planet doing it she's doing it
in a major way just Khan beat her before
another promotion hot second ago so
Jessica Khan she's very credentialed as
far as legit ghee Jiu Jitsu very
credentialed Dana Kelly just she's a
professional so you see there's a
different Dynamic there Daniel Kelly's
not worried about the ibj FF all those
that stuff 80cc she's not she don't care
about any of that all she cares about is
being professional win this title so who
I'm siding with so I'm excited man